a bell has rung for more than 200
years during its history the
baccar foundry has produced around 120,000
pockets and the no bell rings
all over the world
pascale picard band
[Music]
my name is pierre pas because i am the
sixth generation
of  the paccard foundry my name is
philippe not because i am the seventh
generation of the paccard foundry my
name is clemente a because i am the
eighth generation of the paccard foundry
story of the packard times begins
in 1996 when it was necessary to rebuild
the whole heritage the bells
destroyed in france by the
french revolution and here and now
7 said why not me
bell founders this transmission is it
is done continuously all
generations
until today a
lot of bells  have
gone abroad we have more than 10,000 bells in
canada we even see more than 10,000 bells
in the united states the biggest bell which is
called the world peace bell which has been
built  ituated the biggest soaring bell
in the world it was thought that
every every minute that passes a
bell not karbasi des moors
[Music]
[Applause]
the bells made by the
paccard house today are still
made according to the same  technical as
it could be when setting
up a business this know-how depends on
three fundamental characteristics the
profile or shape of the class the
quality of the metal the bells are actually made of
bronze and then the third
very important parameter is  is the ability of the
master tuner to
sound a bell our principal surrounded
by several harmonies and for a
bell to have a beautiful sound,
the harmonics must be perfectly
harmonized between m we are here in front
of a 4 ton oven which goes  coming to
heat the metal directly
[Music]
my favorite part of the process well
I would say it's still the rain
[Music]
we feel the heat of the molten metal
we see it dripping  ler in the mold and so
it's really a moment that has a lot
of emotion and is very beautiful
[Music]
game must have been six or seven years old
when I started to really run
in the company all that is
today I'm 16 so I
'm still at school so suddenly I
can't work every day at
the company the casting of a bell we
don't see many of them in the world
it's  exceptional and that I have always
had this this vocation since
I was very small I said to
myself I have to work here it makes me very
proud that my children can continue
the tradition what is important is that
they are there  find a great joy a
great motivation it is by profession of
passion and him but to express a wish
is that the bells still glow for
many, many years
[Music]